uh so let's start my name is maximum
Charlie as you heard uh it might sound a
bit French but actually I'm Belgian
um
but I'm living in France I'm a
consultant facilitator in training
working for a company that is called
ardling uh the company which is
organizing DDD Europe conference
um I'm also an even storming early
adopter and we will speak about this
tool as well in that talk I'm
co-organizing the new crafts conference
in Paris each year next year will be the
10th anniversary edition so quite
excited about it uh 2023 videos are
already online with a talk by Nick
including At All by Nick but other as
well I'm also part of the virtual DDD
team and virtual DD is a website
which.com where you should go
and this is a place where you can find
online resources about DDD uh it's only
online stuff like presentation workshops
panel decisions whatever so there's a
lot of thing going on you can go on the
website and see uh the next show is
planned I think next month
it's up to unique
so light Max I'm a consultant I recently
spent three years writing a book which
is almost finished
if you've got any questions about
writing a book all the things that can
go wrong
all the stress what the stress is like
I'll be very happy to share my
experiences with you but it's been a
very rewarding experience and I would
encourage you to write a book I'm also
the co-organizer of the domain driven
design London Meetup
and if ever you're in London please drop
by trying to do meetups every month
also always on the lookout for speakers
if you've got some topic
DVD not DDD if you're a first-time
speaker
we're very happy to welcome you so yeah
please get in touch if you're interested
in attending or speaking
Max let's get to the juice what are we
what are we going to cover today so
a lot of companies
get stuck adding new features takes a
long time
only be able to develop software faster
having a Loosely coupled architecture is
an important part in that process so
teams can work independently make
changes independently I don't think
there's any controversy there
what we're going to show you today is
that in our experience achieving Loosely
coupled architecture
benefits from having a domain your own
approach if you can identify parts of
your domain that are somewhat
independent you can get a more Loosely
coupled architecture
but how are we going to answer those
questions yeah so that's the the talk
structure so first of all we will see
how even storming can help us to map out
the domain of our company and then based
on the result of those even storming
sessions we will be able to identify
domain boundaries but then as a second
step we will see that we need to refine
those boundaries to gain more confidence
in those and we will do that by testing
them against a real domain use cases and
we will use a technical domain message
role modeling that will be the the
second step of the stock and then at the
end we will see how the bound contacts
canvas
can help us as a third refinement tool
to to be able to define the roles and
the responsibilities of each boundaries
we found
yep
so we have a little role play now
you will be the CEO of this company
thing so max
I hired you as a CTO some years ago
sorry
I hired you as a CTO some years ago Max
okay and you've always performed well
for this company
for the difficult times we've had the
good times and about you've been a great
CTO I've got a mission for you now
and it's the biggest biggest challenge
that the company has faced I need to
know if you can help us the industry is
really hotting up
over the next five years we're going to
have to double our Revenue to capitalize
on all of these new opportunities
because if we don't
the competition will
can you do that or do I need to find a
new CTO
well well well
um okay uh yeah you forget maybe about
something very very important okay you
want to improve the system but we have a
very very very very all Legacy system
and that will be quite a bit difficult
so I will have to ask also my principal
engineer what he thinks about it because
alone I'm not sure I will be able to do
that
okay and talk to your principal engineer
get his opinion and let me know I'll
catch up with you in a couple of days
so principal engineer uh what do you
think about all this uh thing that we
need to uh double or multiply our
revenue and that we need to increase our
velocity and whatever so what's your
opinion on that well you know we've been
telling you we need to spend some time
refactoring our system on improving the
technical debt because it's very
difficult to work with and you've never
allowed us to do that Mr CTO and so I
just I don't think we can even deploy
the monolith once in five years let
alone deploying 50 times a day
all right
um no well we're kidding but we're very
serious now Nick so uh I really want you
to uh
to think about how we we could get there
what what's your what's in your mind
right now okay I'll put my grudges with
you to one side and I'll think about how
can we achieve this Mission together and
repair our
relationship so you know my my
observations are
teams are used to working in a monolith
and fixing bugs adding new features I
just don't think the team we've got has
the experience or the knowledge or the
mindset to just do something radical
like this all right all right so I think
that might be a problem here yeah I
understand so I've recently read the
book which is called team topologies and
they they say in that book that we need
not to have to siled themes but instead
we have we should have stream aligned
teams that are all working independently
uh with fast flow so that would be very
very good I think for uh for the
objectives the business is asking us to
fulfill so yeah how how could we get
there
if I could do this will I get a
promotion
yes sure okay so I've got an idea I've
got an idea how we can achieve this so
I've been reading this stuff on GitHub
called it's the DDD crew it's a bunch of
resources from people who are
practitioners of the major and design
it's some ideas about how we can go
about
refactoring our system getting it more
domain driven and I think if we take
that approach we can get to that team
topology's vision of stream align teams
if I remember correctly I was reading
something about a technique called event
stormy and I think we should probably
start there yeah so I gave it a go
please do it thanks
let's give it a try okay
so as we talked about
um if we're going to think about how to
create Loosely coupled architecture one
of the first steps in that journey is
looking at the business domain we're
working in how do we break up this
domain into different areas how can we
approach to that task different
techniques out there the one we're
a technique where fond of what we use
the most I would say
is called event storming so as you can
see here vent storming is a very simple
idea
if you haven't seen it it involves
putting orange Post-its along the
timeline and the Post-its represent the
main events so in this example here
we're describing some Journey where
someone located a scooter on the app
they went to the scooter and they trying
to start a journey and we can see there
are different flows here on the bottom
flow the customer wasn't able to find a
scooter so we've got happy cases and
we've got edge cases
modeling various flows and parts of the
domain we can zoom into the details and
zoom out as we need to it's not a
structured technique where everything
must be a certain level of detail it's
quite a messy approach
and so here's how it looks in real life
you get a lot of people you try and get
as many different perspectives as
possible in this example here
we had people from sales marketing
customer support developers the CEO the
CTO and the CEO were there and this was
the result of a whole day's worth of
event storming we mapped out this
end-to-end flow and the group identified
15 or more potential
sub domains we call them into manger and
design there
and what was interesting about this is
there were lots of interesting
conversations and discoveries along the
way it turned out there was a process
with 180 steps how can you have 180
steps in a process it turns out there
were lots of variations and the sales
team had been improvising with the tools
they had of course there were some
spreadsheets involved so all of this
information comes to the surface people
can see the bigger picture sharing
insights across different roles and
skills products and developers hadn't
really had a relationship where they
work together so closely so a real a
real
moment for this group of people to work
in a different way and that's what event
storming is about it's a great starting
point for the architecture because
raises a lot of interesting insights and
it gives you this nice Advance store
that you can partition as we can see
here
so
this is a hypothetical example not a
real example but as you can see once
you've got an event store mapped out
then you can really start thinking about
architecture this is how our business
works the event storming describes
what's there now
it doesn't propose any structure it
doesn't force you to make any choices
it's just a case of
here's how our business works and from
that point from that unbiased
perspective well you will have some
biases you'll have kind of worked in a
system you'll you'll think certain
things are related so it's not
completely unbiased but with this
flattened out version of your business
you can then start thinking about how
might we split this up what would be
different areas that a team could own
that would lead us to a Loosely coupled
software architecture as well
once you've started identifying those
sub domains it's quite useful to
actually get into the details a bit go a
level deeper and start verifying things
so in this example here we've got a pick
up and drop off sub main this is about
someone's bought a car online and the
company has to drop it off at their
house
so we start by writing down the purpose
of the sub domain already that can give
us some Clues and then we can go through
each event and just say does this feel
like it belongs here you know we're not
we're not getting into anything precise
at this point we're just asking
do these events all feel related so
picked up the new car from the warehouse
well that's kind of in the name of the
sub main pickup sounds good
arrived at the customer's house
offloaded the car these all sound like
events related to pick up and drop-offs
so it feels like we've made a good
choice here
let me get two question marks we've got
Gabe the new owner a guide of the car
hmm
is that you know it's part of this
process of dropping off the car and
helping the customer to take ownership
but maybe a guide of the car might be
something separate and also break down
insurance
that feels like it might not be quite
related here so at this point we'll just
exploring possible boundaries and having
high level conversations we're not
trying to be too precise not trying to
get locked into any particular choices
just exploring and we can do this as a
whole group
because there's nothing overly technical
here we can discuss the main boundaries
with anyone in our company who has an
interest
so as you go through this process you'll
have to pick between different
heuristics for finding the boundaries
and as often as a competition so it's
good to know about the different
heuristics you've got to choose from
so this example here simplest possible
approach take some process you break it
up into steps and each step in the
process is a separate subdomain
this example here is a place order
journey search and browse product
details cartoon checkout
it might be the right boundaries for
this company they might not be it's one
heuristic
another approach is where you identify
these process-based subdomains and then
you start to ask the question are we
seeing anything common across these
processes or Journeys that might make
sense extracting and consolidating into
its own specific something
of course if you look at the two options
here
with approach a we've got no
dependencies or no visible dependencies
we could talk about change coupling
but in the second option we've decided
we're going to have this sub domain that
deals with everything about
notifications these other sub domains
don't have to worry about that anymore
but at the cost of a dependency
and then thirdly if you're into domain
during design you'll know that people in
DDD always talk about language look at
the way people talk about your domain
and that gives a lot of clues about how
you might want to slice your domain
boundaries
in this example here we've got the
concept of a customer in person we're
talking about one actual person
but in different parts of our business
we have a more specific name for that
person when they're trying to achieve a
specific person in this example we've
got a lead
the marketing team might use a rider in
the context of taking a journey and an
account holder when we're talking about
billing so three different heuristics
there process based consolidation based
language based these are the kind of
things we can look for in an event
storming session and we can experiment
with the advanced storm it's very easy
to explore different possible boundaries
all right all right seems good
um I had excellent feedback from uh
those sessions you've made the event
storming so uh I I well I think it went
great so I can have a promotion now then
ah let's wait a little bit uh can you
tell me a bit more about about high rise
uh no about about the even storming okay
so how it went
yeah it was I think it went good I'm
glad you heard some good feedback I
enjoyed the sessions working with lots
of different people and uh we've got
some good ideas about how we could
evolve the system
good ideas
yeah we've identified what could be some
possible sub domains that could be the
right way to model our teams and system
could
should
or could
because I think uh we should maybe now
try to uh to be sure that those
boundaries should be the right one so
how we would do that
well I think here you are again with
your unrealistic expectations this is
what I was talking about earlier so what
we've done so far we've used event
storming we found some possible
boundaries but you know we're kind of at
a high level we haven't really got into
the details and thought about how we
might do that and so we need to go a
level deeper and identify
how this thing might fit together as a
software architecture before I can say
to you we've actually got the final
choices all right I understand okay
let's go for it
all right so
um as Nick said uh during the even
storming session you were able to
identify the the boundaries of your
domain but this is really your first uh
draft uh this is this is not what become
your uh your software architecture or
your boundaries of your software those
are just bets in the future and you
don't want to build your entire platform
on bets I guess so yeah so you need to
find a way to make sure those boundaries
are realistic so uh how do I know if my
boundaries are right so
um
those
refinement cycles that we are entering
right now has already been told by Eric
Evans this is a good idea to do and so
he built this model explosion Whirlpool
where he explained that you need to
enter into different refinement Cycles
until you find the right the right model
or the right boundary so this is not new
this is something Eric Evans has already
been doing so uh Eric by the way is the
author of The DDD Blue Book so first of
all you need to collect scenarios so
this is what Nick done and explained
with the even storming you you go with
your domain experts you ask them to tell
stories so you collect reference
scenarios with them and then you will
have to walk through those scenario to
be able to propose a model for for them
and then as soon as you have enough
information you can start doing some
code probe and if you feel like you
don't have enough information or there's
still gray area so you get again go in
into another refinement cycle and ask
your domain experts for more information
uh when you will be doing those
refinement Cycles you will also be
looking at the coupling between your
different subdomains and vladi kernanov
has an interesting formula about how to
measure coupling between two different
components or systems and this formula
helps you to measure the pain of
coupling which is quite interesting
so first of all you need to think about
the strengths which is how much coupled
your systems are together so if it's
just a system that emits an event and
then there's another system that has
subscribed to this event while you have
a coupling but it's quite low but if you
have multiple micro Services let's say
that share a single database well here
the strength is very high so you have a
very high coupling here very great
strength the volatility is How likely
your two couple systems will change
together better how much they will have
to change together whenever someone is
making a change in system a does it have
an impact on system B so if it's uh well
sometimes so the volatility is so but it
is low but if it's always the case that
when you modify a you have an impact on
B then the quality is high and the
distance is how far those two coupled
things are far away or not if it's in
the same team I mean if the same team is
handling two couple system so the
distance is is near zero so it doesn't
matter so the the pain will be lower but
if you think about two systems that are
coupled that one team is working in
Sydney and the other one in Copenhagen
so yeah everything will be async so the
distance is really great and the pain
will increase and of course the more the
pain the less likely it will be able to
change anything in your system
so to identify those uh to refine and to
be sure that our boundaries are better
defined and then we can have a look at
the coupling as well we will use the
domain message flow modeling technique
which is another one available on the
DDD crew GitHub repository and how does
this work it's really simple first of
all you collect the reference scenarios
as Rick Evans already said in this
Whirlpool process then you will pick up
one and you will start with with an
actor or a system or a domain as a
starting point and then you will create
a message that need to be sent and you
will add the recipient and you connect
the both with the line and you repeat
until you're done so it seems quite
simple let's take an example another
simple example as well and here we have
the scenario where you're placing an
online order when all items are in stock
and this is the first pass is very
important is that you need to be very
explicit about out what you are
why you are doing this diagram here you
know already that all items are in stock
so you won't have to check for those
items in stock of course in this diagram
so uh it's the same if you want to deal
with edge cases here is just the the
happy pass so if you want to test your
boundaries against a scenario where the
payment would fail or the payment
platform will be down so you will have
to create a new diagram in a new
scenario where the payment platform is
down for example so as I as I said you
start with any kind of actor domain or
system so here's the Shopper with this
app it place an order on sales boundary
and the sales boundary is emitting in
the bin or an event order place which is
interesting for billing so the building
knows now that it has to charge the
credit card and as soon as it's done it
will emit another event payment
collected for sales to update the state
of the other maybe and also it will send
a notification and send an email back to
the Shopper so this is quite very simple
but this is the way it works and it's
very easy uh to uh to use those kind of
diagram
um to uh to see how your different
boundaries are interacting with each
other uh based on a a specific scenario
you can add some more information if you
want to add the payload of the message
for example what kind of data is needed
inside all the different events or
command or queries that you would do
during this scenario you can add it as
well but maybe as a second step
so why this technique is very
interesting is that first of all it's
pretty easy to do and second is that
well you can easily spot design smells
or potential issues in your design so
just by looking at it this is the the
power or visualizer visualizing thing is
that you can already maybe spot some
patterns or things that might go wrong
or that are not well designed and in the
first example for example the customer
is making through the app a command on a
on a service let's say and the service
needs to
do four different queries because before
it can handles the the command
uh to fulfill the the order first so uh
here you might think well
maybe we could change the design uh in a
way that when the customer is making
that comment this boundary here has
already enough information without to
have to query about other things or it
might be that it's a perfect design for
a current situation where you would like
to extract a service from a legacy
system and the Legacy system still owns
the data and you are still obliged to
query again and again this Legacy until
you own the data in your own service so
that could be also explaining a
particular situation where you are
migrating from a model it to some some
microservices architecture for example
in the second example that's the same
you can easily see that well the the
boundary in the middle is just acting
like passing message to the other so
whenever you need to do to do a comment
on the first one it needs to call
another one through uh this one but
maybe again this is a good choice
because that could be a platform or
Gateway or whatever in front of
different other services so
by just doing that you can create your
own diagrams and if you want another
perspective on that you can give it to
another team and ask them well what do
you think about it even if they don't
know about your domain or the feature
you're working on just by looking at it
it's very easy to maybe spot some some
problems
you can also easily visualize different
options uh I won't go in detail for that
one but in the first option we have
several boundaries we have a discount
decider discount calculator personal
account so on and in option two they
simplified the way it was done by making
maybe some some query up front so that
the cells have enough information to
call the discount calculator so we can
get a get rid of the discount decider
those are two options so uh you now have
the ability to to vote or ask your team
to vote on which one is the best or
doing pros and cons on those two options
it's really easy to copy and paste but
please if you if you do the first option
and then if someone in the team says
like well um I do not agree I would like
to do this and that well stop him or he
or she and and create a new diagram
before starting discussing don't discuss
something which is not visualized please
so as soon as it's visualized it's
easier to see the differences between uh
the the different options
and here's the case study
um I have done with a company that was
migrating a huge accounting Legacy
system
and they tried first to extract the
fixed asset module and here's a scenario
about fixed asset sales how the sales of
fixed asset is working and first of all
they they uh they did this this event
storming they came out with uh like
different boundaries and those four
boundaries in Step One were the one that
were supposed to uh
to be there to fulfill this fixed asset
sales scenario uh but then they they
they saw that it was not that that
efficient and too much maybe too much
dependencies to go shopping or too tiny
uh things so they decided to bring back
um different different uh thing inside
the same boundary so we have now the
sales Revolution instead of having a
different thing and then another person
came and said well actually uh for all
the the computations uh we really need
different skills for that team so uh it
will be separate people so they they
should be inside another team working
only on algorithms and stuff like that
so they decided to put all the Computing
into one boundary and keep the fix as
itself and and keep this sale behavior
in this fixed asset so you see that it's
not always that you have big boundaries
and you want to decompose them into
smaller ones it's sometimes the the
other where one round that you have
small boundaries and you realize that it
will make too much coupling and too much
communication between all those pieces
of systems and then you want to simplify
this
so yeah this technique is very very cool
because it's very easy to use it will
let you identify the interaction
dependencies the coupling between uh all
your the part of your systems and of
course you will as I said validate
through real use cases of your of your
domain
it will help out to to see the different
coupling of in your in your boundary so
you can you can maybe try to lower that
coupling by having multiple options uh
and visualize them and you will see how
your systems are communicating with each
other and so of course at the end you
have better defined boundaries
great go back to that so uh how did it
go
you said now I need a bit more time to
be sure that my boundaries are right I I
give you that time so now I think you're
done right
pretty much
um except I think we we just need
so we've we've made some improvements I
think from the initial proposal it's
feeling a bit a bit more concrete people
are feeling like yeah we could kind of
start to implement that but I still feel
um
some doubts not 100 but you know I think
you're never 100 so I feel like we're
ready to implement the first step
all right okay
that would be great actually if we could
send a good sign to uh the the board uh
by by making this uh First Step by three
months would it be possible
I think where my head is right now we've
done all this message for modeling we've
got all these scenarios mapped out I
think we just need to consolidate it to
put all that together and to clearly
articulate what is it we're going to try
and build in the first three to six
months I feel like if we do that I can
come back to you with a very concrete
proposal and uh yeah I feel positive
right now okay think about yourself that
are increased
yep see you in a few moment then
cool so
I'm gonna quickly talk now about service
roles and responsibilities so
we've identified these possible domain
boundaries we've done some message flow
modeling
we've got these different perspectives
on our boundaries
and before you start implementing it's
always a good idea to just consolidate
what you've got into a single picture
and say
does this all look cohesive does it make
sense can we start implementing it
and so that's what the bounded context
canvas is useful for you can take all of
your scenarios involving a particular
service particular context and put them
all together in one overall view it's
not a magic tool but it's one way to
structure all the information
so let's have a look at the canvas
itself it's I think there were nine
sections there and basically what we're
touching on at the top is you know
what's the name what's the purpose how
important is this from a business
perspective and at the bottom what we're
looking at is what are the
responsibilities in terms of what does
it have to handle coming from other
parts of the system and what responses
does it need to give and what are some
of the business rules and the key of the
main terms inside there like trying to
capture every single thing here but all
the key details so we can actually make
that decision let's do this
so we've got an example here which is a
bookings service
you can see from the description it
handles all the bookings all the
bookings every single booking it handles
it it's highly customizable so the
purpose is telling us there's a clear
intention here to handle something very
generic and if we look at the bottom of
the canvas we can kind of see that we've
got these crud events create order
update order delete order these are
normally words we use when we're talking
about databases and more technical
things so
there's a lot of things we can we can
take from this canvas the first one is
on on a top on the top on the business
level
why are we trying to create something so
generic
why are we trying to handle all the
bookings for all possible scenarios is
the purpose just wrong here before we
analyze the design are we trying to
solve something here that just shouldn't
be solved in this way
and then looking at those messages we
talked about we might realize oh
we thought the purpose was to do
something generic and we've built this
generic system but actually we could
have built something much more specific
so
the key thing is we've got all of this
in one place and we can just have a
quick overall check and clarify is it
good is it not good do we implement or
do we need to spend some more time in
design here
next example is this Fleet Management
thing and I'm going to use the word
thing because it's
it's big and it's hairy and it doesn't
know when to delegate to other things
so what we can see here straight away is
the number of collaborators on both
sides there's a little four on the left
four on the right and actually on the
right it's got many consumers so already
that's a warning sign
we've got the word management as well
which is normally an indicator that
we're using a generic word because we
can't describe more clearly what this is
doing
and if we look if we start looking at
those messages down there I need to
squint a bit we can start imagining how
might we pull those things out so
get the scooter location
check out the scooter check in the
scooter okay there's some cohesion there
demand forecasted wow that does not seem
related to the Scooter's location so
we can imagine how we might pull that
apart
as we talked about naming is quite
important and this is one of the first
hurdles where we can have a lot of
conversations so I think there's a
couple of tips I would keep in mind a
couple of little cliches or the first
one generic names attract generic
Behavior if you see words like
management
then you can put a lot of things in
there
and the name doesn't tell you that
doesn't belong here if you use a more
specific a more precise name it's clear
when you're adding something into a
service that doesn't logically belong
there
something else you can do with the
canvas when you've got all the
collaborators in one place is you can go
through each of those dependencies you
can apply vladox formula as Maxine was
talking about
and you can go through the different
um
different tips here so for every
dependency you can ask what would it
take to remove that dependency from the
system
maybe you can remove a dependency
but that will result in some duplication
somewhere else so you can explore those
options
um another one the third point I'd say
the third Point here is the really
interesting thing that always comes up
looking at the names of those messages
where's the service getting its data
from am I getting the Scooter's location
from the pricing service because that is
really not something that should be
happening so looking at those messages
looking at the data that's moving around
looking at where it's come from and it's
and it's going to that can really throw
up some weird design choices
I think it's time to wrap things up Max
I've got a promotion party to go to so
let's bring this home
so yeah as a wrap-up I will show you
this picture of the domain driven design
starter modeling process which is
another resource that you can find on
DDD crew GitHub repository and this is
kind of the the view of what DDD is is
covering the holistic view of what it is
covering from aligning from your
business model and username discovering
your domain until code so you have the
discovering part you have the Strategic
part of DDD and you have the Tactical
part of EDD on that picture so we you
have a lot of different steps and of
course there's no there's not a single
way to go through those steps it's
really depending on your context
it might be that you will go to discover
you will have enough information to go
directly into code and maybe you will
realize that you are you have some
missing information so you will go back
to that that's that that's why we have
those arrows which are the same rows as
in the the Whirlpool model of
exploration of Eric events of course
course you will go back at Force it's
iterative it's very important you will
you will experiment even in the code
sometimes get get more feedback and then
realize that well it's not enough and
you need to go back discover again a bit
more your domain decomposing a bit more
connecting stuff so what we've been
through uh during this talk is those
different steps uh even zooming inside
the Discover part uh obviously where you
will discover your domain uh
collaboratively with all the
stakeholders and then it will decompose
it uh
into subdomains and this will be your
first boundaries that you will have to
refine and then you can use the domain
message for modeling to refine those
monaries for example and then in this
connect phase you will you will try how
things are talking to each other if
there's not too much chattiness or
whatever and in the Define section this
is where you gather all the information
you've collected from the previous steps
and you put it at the single place and
you will see if it makes sense or not
and based on that you can have more
feedback and go back maybe if you need
more information so
yeah really depending on your context uh
you you might not have to have those
steps maybe you you want just to uh
focus on on strategize stuff or organize
your team so that those are different uh
steps here that are described in uh on
the on the GitHub page and there's a lot
of different tools that you can use for
each step so uh there's even storming
there's domain missile traveling but
there are other tools that are available
for uh for this uh so please have a look
at this page and you will see a lot of
tools and maybe tools that you are
already using in your company so yep
so we've talked about these techniques
and I think it's one thing to talk about
the techniques but it's a different
thing to actually apply these Concepts
in your company
and this mail may not apply to you but
in a lot of companies doing stuff like
event storming requires a mindset shift
so let's say for example
I'm talking to CTO or CEO they've got
some big projects and it's like oh event
storming is perfect here let's get
people together let's map this all out
and let's really figure things out
before we start building stuff and
reshaping the system
and we'll give him a shopping list like
not a shopping list but an attendee list
let's say
um let's get this team this team these
experts this product person
and they'll say something like that's a
lot of developers can I just bring the
tech lead instead and those developers
can keep working back in the office so
I think what these all of these
techniques that we're talking about
really depend on having a an openness to
collaborating and getting different
perspectives in the room from all across
your company being willing to map things
out visually I see there's a lot of
resistance sometimes oh it's going to
get together put some Post-its on the
wall it's all that hippie stuff you know
if you're not typing then it doesn't
matter so
I'm not going to stand here and try and
convince you I'm just going to say if
you do want to go down this approach
then an openness to visual collaboration
is
it's quite essential
here are some links and books we
recommend and
that's everything from us any final
words from you Max
no it's okay thank you very much thank
you and congrats for your increase
congratulations for your increase salary
increase